a big an actress who has nominated for  touching performance in the film called  sounder and who will soon be seen as a  woman called Moses even sooner right  here should be seen as her charming self  Cicely Tyson  the next award will be given by a  gentleman who was a distinguished  filmmaker 10 years before the Academy  was founded ladies and gentlemen someone  who is responsible for great many of the  true classics mr. King Vidor  mr. video I can't tell you how honored I  am to be standing on the stage alongside  of you and together we will announce the  nominees for the Best Director the  pleasure is mine Thank You Woody Allen  for Annie Hall even Spielberg of Close  Encounters of the Third Kind  bread cinnamon for Julia  and George Lucas for Star Wars perfect  Ross for the turning point  the winner is huh  Woody Allen  the Academy congratulate Woody Allen and  accepts this award on his behalf